Before there was a city here, there was only this.
Forest, ice, and a river that froze solid for half of every year.
Nothing about this place promised greatness.
The nearest thing to a road was the river itself.
And here is the other thing you need to know before we begin.
Moscow burns.
Again and again across eight centuries, this city has been burned to the ground.
And every single time, it grew back.
That is the real story.
Not conquest, not glory.
Survival, and the stubborn habit of rebuilding on ash.
In the twelfth century, this was the edge of the known Russian world.
Dense forest, frozen marsh, and trading paths.
A borderland that mattered to almost nobody.
Kyiv was the centre of Russian life then, and Kyiv was far to the south.
In eleven forty seven, a prince named Yuri Dolgoruky called a meeting at a small wooden outpost on a hill above the Moskva river.
That single line is the first time Moscow appears in writing.
He was inviting an ally to dinner.
The chronicle records the meal, not a founding.
He did not found a capital.
He fortified a waypoint.
A timber wall, a few hundred people, and a good position between two rivers.
That was all Moscow was.
Its value was traffic, not power.
And a wooden town in open forest has one defining weakness.
It cannot survive fire, and it cannot survive cavalry.
Within a century it would face both at once.
In twelve thirty seven, riders came out of the east carrying news nobody wanted to believe.
Something enormous was moving across the steppe, and it was moving toward them.
They had perhaps a year of warning, and it made no difference at all.
The Mongols under Batu Khan did not raid.
They erased.
Russian city after Russian city fell in weeks, and the armies sent to stop them simply ceased to exist.
Riazan refused to surrender and was annihilated.
Vladimir, seat of the grand prince, fell in three days.
Moscow's turn came in the winter of twelve thirty eight.
The walls were wood.
The defenders were few.
The town was taken and burned in a matter of days.
It was not considered important enough to be remembered as a great siege.
What remained was ash on frozen ground.
For any ordinary settlement that is the end of the record.
A name in a chronicle, and nothing written after it.
But people came back to the hill.
They rebuilt in timber, knowing it would burn again, because the position was worth the risk.
That decision made everything that followed possible.
Timber was cheap, and the rivers still met here.
For the next two hundred years, Russia lived under the Golden Horde.
Princes did not rule.
They paid, they knelt, and they waited.
The Horde issued a document called the yarlyk, and whichever prince held it ruled on the Khan's behalf.
And this is where Moscow does something genuinely unexpected.
It did not rise by fighting the Mongols.
It rose by working for them.
Ivan the first earned a nickname that tells you everything.
Kalita.
Moneybag.
He persuaded the Horde to let Moscow collect the tribute owed by every other Russian principality.
It was a tax farm, and Moscow was running it.
Every year the silver passed through Moscow's hands on its way east.
And every year a portion of it did not continue the journey.
The city grew rich on the arrangement.
The city bought land, absorbed its neighbours, and paid for churches.
Within two generations it was the strongest principality in the north.
By thirteen eighty, Moscow was strong enough to stop paying.
Prince Dmitry met the Horde's army at Kulikovo, on open ground, and won.
The Horde had fractured into rival factions, and Dmitry judged the moment correctly.
It was the first time a Russian army had beaten the Mongols in the field.
A psychological wall broke that day.
But be careful with this victory.
He took the name Donskoy from the river he fought beside.
Two years later the Horde came back and burned Moscow again.
Real independence took another full century, and when it came, it came under Ivan the third.
In fourteen eighty, Ivan refused the tribute and faced the Horde across the Ugra river.
Both armies waited.
Then the Mongols turned and rode away.
Two and a half centuries ended without a battle.
It is remembered as the Great Stand on the Ugra, and it is one of the quietest endings to an empire on record.
Ivan then did something deliberate.
He demolished the old white stone Kremlin and brought Italian architects to rebuild it in red brick.
Those are the walls you still see today.
The Italians brought the brick, the engineering, and the swallowtail battlements you can still count along the top of the wall.
In fifteen forty seven his grandson was crowned with a title no Russian ruler had used before.
Not prince.
Tsar.
From the word Caesar.
This was not a change of rank.
It was a claim to inherit the authority of Rome itself.
Moscow now claimed to be the third Rome.
The first fell to barbarians, the second to the Ottomans, and this city declared itself the last one left standing.
The man who took that title was sixteen years old.
He began as a reformer.
He ended as something the Russian language gave a permanent name to.
His mother was poisoned when he was eight, and he grew up surrounded by the men he suspected of doing it.
Ivan the fourth.
Grozny.
Usually translated as terrible, though the word sits closer to formidable, or awe inspiring.
Both readings turned out to be accurate.
He built this.
Saint Basil's cathedral, raised to mark the conquest of Kazan, is the most recognisable building in Russia, and it came out of his reign.
Nine chapels on a single foundation, and no two of them alike.
He also built the oprichnina.
A private force answering to him alone, with authority to seize, torture and execute without explanation and without appeal.
They rode in black, on black horses, carrying a broom and a severed dog's head as their emblem.
For seven years the state made war on its own population.
Entire cities were purged.
Novgorod, a rival trading power, was broken so thoroughly it never recovered.
And while the Tsar was hunting enemies inside his own borders, the real enemy was quietly assembling outside them.
In fifteen seventy one the Crimean Tatars rode north, went around the army entirely, and set Moscow alight.
The city burned almost completely in a single day.
The death toll was enormous, and the estimates still vary widely.
The Kremlin walls held.
Almost nothing outside them did.
Ivan's dynasty died with his sons.
What followed is called the Time of Troubles.
Famine, pretenders, civil war, and finally a Polish garrison sitting inside the Kremlin itself.
By sixteen eleven Moscow was occupied, burned again, and leaderless.
This is the closest Russia has ever come to simply ceasing to exist as a state.
A Polish garrison held the fortress, a Swedish army held the north, and there was no agreed Tsar anywhere.
The recovery did not come from the throne.
It came from a merchant in Nizhny Novgorod, a butcher named Kuzma Minin, who raised the money and the men alongside a prince named Pozharsky.
They marched on Moscow with an army raised by public subscription, not by a crown.
In sixteen twelve they retook the Kremlin.
A new dynasty, the Romanovs, took the throne the following year, and held it for the next three hundred.
The day they entered the Kremlin is still a national holiday.
And then Moscow lost the one thing it had spent centuries acquiring.
In seventeen twelve, Peter the Great moved the capital to his new city on the Baltic.
Saint Petersburg was built facing Europe.
Moscow was left facing its own past.
For two hundred years Moscow was the old capital.
Respected, ceremonial, and no longer the place where decisions were made.
The city went quiet.
Which is what makes the next chapter so strange.
The most famous event in Moscow's entire history happened while Moscow was not the capital at all.
Eighteen twelve.
The largest army Europe had ever assembled crossed into Russia with a single objective.
Force one decisive battle, and dictate the peace.
Napoleon brought more than half a million men.
The Russian armies refused him the battle he needed.
They retreated instead, and burned the supplies behind them as they went.
It was the largest invasion force assembled in Europe up to that point.
He reached Moscow in September and found something no conqueror plans for.
The city was empty.
Almost the entire population had left.
There was nobody there to surrender to him.
A conqueror needs somebody to accept defeat.
There was nobody left in the building.
That night, fires started in several districts at once.
The city's firefighting equipment had been removed before the French arrived.
Most of the city was still built out of wood.
Over four days, roughly three quarters of Moscow burned.
Whether an order was given, or the fires spread from looting, is argued to this day.
The effect was not ambiguous.
The governor of the city had ordered the fire pumps removed before he left.
Napoleon held the capital and gained nothing from it.
No supplies, no winter shelter, no government to negotiate with.
He waited five weeks for a peace offer that never arrived.
The retreat began in October.
Of the men who marched into Russia, only a small fraction marched out.
The army that had beaten every power in Europe was destroyed by a city that refused to be occupied.
Cold, hunger and constant attack finished what the fire had started.
A century later the empire collapsed from the inside.
Nineteen seventeen brought revolution, and with it a decision that reversed Peter's.
The Bolsheviks moved the capital back to Moscow in nineteen eighteen.
The imperial eagles came down from the Kremlin towers.
Red Square became the stage of a global ideology.
Moscow was now the centre of a state that intended to remake the entire world in its image.
Foreign delegations came to study it, and foreign governments came to fear it.
In the nineteen thirties the eagles were replaced with red stars of ruby glass, lit from inside.
They are still up there, and they still turn in the wind.
And then, for the fourth time in its history, an army came for this city with the stated intention of ending it.
In the autumn of nineteen forty one, German forces advanced to within sight of Moscow.
Some units reached the last tram stop on the edge of the city.
Officers could see the buildings of the city through their field glasses.
The city did not fully evacuate.
Factories kept running.
Civilians dug anti tank ditches by hand, and in December, in extreme cold, the Red Army counterattacked.
The military parade on Red Square went ahead that November, and the troops marched from it directly to the front line.
The advance stopped there permanently.
It was the first major failure of that army, and it happened at the gates of a city that had already survived three burnings.
What followed was construction on an enormous scale.
Wide avenues, a metro built like a palace, and seven towers that still define the skyline.
Much of it was raised by a population that had just lost tens of millions of people.
And in December nineteen ninety one the flag above the Kremlin came down, and the state that had built all of it ceased to exist, almost overnight.
Moscow absorbed that too.
Today it holds more than twelve million people, and the towers of its financial district stand a few kilometres from walls raised in the fourteen hundreds.
The two sit inside the same skyline, and neither one looks out of place.
Look at the whole sequence at once and the pattern is hard to miss.
Burned by the Mongols.
Burned by the Tatars.
Occupied by the Poles.
Burned again in eighteen twelve.
Besieged in nineteen forty one.
Five times destroyed or nearly taken.
Five times rebuilt, on the same hill, above the same river, by people who kept deciding the position was worth the risk.
That is not really a story about empire.
It is a story about a decision made over and over, usually by ordinary people standing in ash, choosing to start again.
Moscow was never inevitable.
It was rebuilt.
Thank you for watching, and if you want the next chapter of this history, tell us in the comments where to go next.